metlife chef claus strunz schön dass du
bei uns bis klaus also ich habe jetzt
wirklich in meinem berufsleben schon
viele grausame dinge gesehen solche
bilder wie die ausputzer habe ich mir
nicht vorstellen können dass ich so was
jemals wirklich hier in europa abspielen
würde was hat das mit dir gemacht das
hat das in mir ausgelöst als das gesehen
hast das ist grausam und ich finde was
andrej melik hervorgehoben hat sich
diese nähe noch mal klar zu machen dass
ist babelsberg das ist potsdam würden
wir in münchen leben würde man sagen das
ist erding in hamburg und sagen das ist
wedelt das ist in der nächsten nähe
einer großen metropole passiert ein
völkermord noch immer ganz kurz
völkermord ist die gezielte ermordung
von menschen die entweder einer rasse
einer ethnie
angehören oder auch sozusagen einer
nation das was wir besichtigen ist
völkermord das muss man einmal deutlich
aussprechen und völkermarkt kann nicht
einfach dazu führen dass man zur
tagesordnung zurück geht zumal es ja
nicht der erste und einzige
völkermordes für den bloody mary putin
verantwortlich ist wird am ende der
neunziger anfang der 2000er
tschetschenien gesehen wir haben
geräuschen 2008 gesehen wir haben
mehrfach daran erinnert dass 2014 die
ukraine überfallen worden ist jedes mal
mit vielen vielen toten jedes mal mit
absurden begründungen in georgien waren
eigene staatsbürger in gefahr und
deshalb musste man dort morden lassen
und morden das gleiche wiederholt sich
wieder es war vorher aufgeschrieben und
niemand hat etwas getan niemand hat das
ernst genommen wir im westen auch wir
hier in deutschland haben business as
usual gemacht wir haben geschäfte
gemacht mit russland wir haben irgendwie
diese alle gleichen verehrt wegen ihrem
reichtum und ihre yachten wir sind teil
eines
moralischen disasters des der westen
jetzt erlebt und gegen das er sich mit
allen mitteln stemmen muss und es nicht
tut aber man fragt sich natürlich auch
warum also ich meine das sind zivilisten
wir haben wirklich diese bilder gesehen
da geht jemand einkaufen da hat
kartoffel noch in der tüte ja oder oder
auch vom fahrrad die sind unbewaffnet
das sind menschen wie du und ich die
wollen einfach nur kurz lebensmittel
kaufen die wollen mal vor die tür
natürlich herrscht krieg sie sind
unbewaffnet warum werden diese menschen
angriff ja das ist eine
widerliche widerlichste an einer
machtdemonstration
wenn soldaten frauen vergewaltigt dann
ist das teil einer kriegsführung dh ihr
gehört mir und ich habe macht über dich
und wenn man sie anschließend umbringen
das ist teil eines völkermords das ist
strategisch geplant das ist ja nicht
dass jetzt eine horde von drei anfang
20-jährigen geistesgestörten jungen
russischen soldaten sich verfehlt das
wäre schlimm genug aber das ist ja
strategisch geplant ist von langer hand
geplant und deshalb ist es einander
weise verwerflich wie ich mich auch
nicht erinnern kann dass ich es in
meiner aktiven zeit als journalist in
nächster nähe gesehen habe ich habe noch
mal ganz kurz nachgeguckt wir sagen ja
immer das ist so nah es ist aber
wirklich war butscher ist von berlin
doppelt so weit entfernt wie hamburg von
münchen das ist nur doppelt so weit das
ist näher als mallorca das ist ne es ist
mehr als alles was uns in der westlichen
welt so präsent ist es gehört zur
westlichen welt und deshalb müssen jetzt
konsequenzen folgen wir müssen aufhören
uns herauszufinden ich gehe sogar noch
weitere gibt jeder von uns muss aufhören
sich herauszuwinden man kann jetzt nicht
mehr sagen ja unser wirtschaft nimmt
dann schaden das spielt jetzt keine
rolle es gilt das gilt jetzt einen
völkermord zu verhindern
zu stoppen er läuft ja schon er läuft
gerade wahrscheinlich jetzt in dieser
minute gerade jetzt in dieser minute
wird wieder irgendeine einheit den
befehl bekommen haben von irgendeinem
befehlshaber der wiederum von wladimir
putin beauftragt ist einen
vernichtungskrieg zu organisieren ist
ein vernichtungskrieg
es ist das was wir in der geschichte in
unserer jüngeren geschichte einmal
gesehen haben uns selber angerichtet
haben das geschieht jetzt vor unser
aller augen und alle die in den letzten
fünfzig sechzig jahren immer wieder
gesagt haben nie wieder das darf nie
wieder passieren müssen jetzt raus aus
ihren wohnungen mit stuck und weg von
ihrem rotwein und weg von ihren flügel
runden wir müssen jetzt selber aktiv
werden und es bedeutet wenn wir sagen
wir wollen kein militär wofür ich bin
wofür ich noch bin dann müssen wir uns
erschwert dass wir gewählt haben die
sanktionen die wirtschaftliche attac die
wirtschaftliche den wirtschaftlichen
feldzug gegen den aggressor in gang
setzen und zwar mit aller macht auch wir
müssen jetzt wovon auch nicht getan
warum gibt es denn überhaupt jetzt noch
möglichkeiten zur sanktionierung einen
apfel oder eine absurde momente und wir
haben olaf scholz ja gerade gehört wie
er sagt wir müssen jetzt weitere
sanktionen machen da frage ich mich
welche will er denn eigentlich noch
machen oder besser gesagt er legt offen
dass bisher gar nicht alles gemacht
worden ist wenn jemand also sagt sie
herr bundeskanzler und die ganzen führer
der westlichen welt sind auch mit schuld
an dem was da geschehen ist dann ist das
der beweis man hätte doch vor vier
wochen schon die chefs möglichen
sanktionen machen können dann wäre das
vielleicht verhindert worden das kann
man nicht beweisen aber man hätte
wenigstens nicht moralische schuld auf
sich geladen das ist geschehen und wenn
ich heute wahrnehmen die kollegen der
welt haben recherchiert dass wir eine
anfrage wir die deutsche bundeswehr eine
anfrage der ukraine nach mehr panzern
abgelehnt haben und irgendwelche
wahrscheinlich wieder verschimmelten
raketen schicken da geht einem doch
sozusagen also das nennt man begreift es
nicht und er jetzt zu sehr in die
anklage alle anderen kommen würde ich
auch noch mal sagen wir alle sitzen in
einem boot also wer jetzt noch etwas
kauft von einem unternehmen von dem man
weiß dass es weiterhin nach russland
liefert macht sich mit schuldig wer
jetzt sozusagen als unternehmen noch
geschäfte mit russland macht macht sich
mitschuldig wer jetzt sagt da muss man
aber verständnis haben auch für putin
der ist auch in der schwierigen
situation macht sich mitschuldig wer
jetzt demos macht in berlin mit
irgendwelchen russen -position demos ist
ein mittäter auf diese demos müssen auf
jeden fall nochmal zu sprechen kommen
das war wirklich endlich was wir hier in
berlin gesehen haben das war ein riesen
autokorso der hier durch die hauptstadt
gezogen ist da wurden russische fahnen
geschwenkt und das perfideste war dass
sie tatsächlich extra auch noch am
hauptbahnhof vorbei gefahren sind dort
wo die ukraine ankommen um ihn auch noch
mal damit offensichtlich zu zeigen wir
sind auch hier dass es unfassbar sind an
das soll das am selben tag wo uns diese
bilder aus burg
die war raffiniert angemeldet die demo
man konnte also bei der demo an wenn ich
merken um was es sich tatsächlich
handelt ich finde es auch eigentlich gar
nicht schlecht dass sie stattgefunden
hat weil man sieht auch wo
meinungsfreiheit die grenzen hat das
sozusagen unter dem deckmantel der
meinungsfreiheit zu machen einen putin
propagandafeldzug am tag an dem ein
völkermord von dem es immer hieß dass er
stattfindet aber den wir jetzt vor augen
haben stattfindet das zeigt auch das
bauch meinungsfreiheit irgendwo und
demonstrationsfreiheit irgendwo grenzen
haben muss ich will auch noch ein wort
zu der russischen bevölkerung sagen
natürlich kann man nicht sagen alle
busse sind jetzt mittäter aber schon
ganz schön viele denn die meisten von
ihnen haben lade mir putin gewählt und
zwar nach 2014 nach 2008 nach anfangen
und sie kennt und 2000 nicht und es war
immer das gleiche und ich lasse auch
jetzt allmählich nicht mehr gelten das
ist halt nicht besser wissen wegen der
propaganda sie hätten es wissen müssen
und auch da schimmert ein motiv durch
das wir in deutschland nur allzu gut
kennen was hätte man denn wissen müssen
aus derzeit aus der nazizeit was hätte
man wissen müsst nicht gewusst haben
schützt vor gar nichts und zwar zu recht
das gilt jetzt auch für die russen und
es kotzt mich langsam an gestattet mir
sozusagen wissen diesen diesen
unsachlichen begriff wenn ich mit russen
spreche und die mir dann sagen dazu
können wir leider nichts sagen weil
sonst kriegen wir selber probleme und so
weiter ist dass sie waren noch putins
krieg es ist putins krieg er ist der
erste das boot ist der völkermörder der
kriegsverbrecher aber all diejenigen die
jetzt schweigen auch in russland die
nicht zu demos gehen können sich nicht
mehr lange darauf beziehen dass sie es
nicht wussten diese bilder erreichen
jeden der sie sehen was müsste das
russische volk vor allem diejenigen die
eben auch hier im ausland leben was
müssen die jetzt in deiner meinung nach
naja sich zeigen sich äußern vor allem
die die nicht mehr in der ultimativen im
zugriff von wladimir putin leben also im
ausland das sind ja viele millionen
menschen wo sind denn die twitter
gruppen die instagram gruppen wo sind
denn wussten der aufschrei ich schäme
mich ein russe zu sein ich schäme mich
jetzt ein russe zu sein unter diesem
anführer wo ist das denn alles es ist
ein allgemeines schweigen mit der
begründung angst ja aber ich glaube dass
jetzt alle sozusagen
lernen müssen und es kommt zu meinem
nächsten wichtigsten punkt was jetzt
gefordert ist von uns zu reden wenn ich
über die andere reden wir über uns reden
wir über deutschland über jeden
einzelnen von uns über unsere regierung
was jetzt und zwar nicht morgen oder
übermorgen sondern heute gefordert ist
ist der sofortige stopp der zahlungen an
wladimir putin ich würde jetzt zur bank
gehen und diese 200 millionen dollar
oder millionen euro zahlen müssen dann
danke fly angebote nicht in überzahl
sofort stoppen der dauerauftrag oder was
immer das ist wird gestoppt was passiert
dann wir wissen es nicht wir wissen
nicht ob die gaslieferung dann
eingestellt wird und wenn sie
eingestellt wird dann wird uns den
schlauen deutschen sicherlich was
einfallen um mit dem problem umzugehen
und wenn es dann arbeitslosigkeit gibt
was die deutsche industrie ankündigt und
was ich sogar glaube dann finde ich ist
das auch teil eines beitrags von uns
denn wenn ein vater oder eine mutter
seinen oder ihren kindern sagen kann ich
bin 2022 arbeitslos geworden weil wir
mussten einen völkermord verhindern wir
müssen einen völkermord stoppen und das
war ein bitterer preis den wir dafür
bezahlt haben dann ist das eine
begründung eines bürgers eines moralisch
integren bürgers das ist was anderes als
wenn man seinen job verliert weil sich
der chef die firma für den aktienmarkt
die taschen voll machen will das ist
dann sozusagen außer jeder diskussion
aber jetzt olaf scholz das heute
verkündet er hat ja weitere sanktionen
angekündigt heute aber er will sich
jetzt abstimmen und olaf scholz ist er
will jetzt auch das alles in butter
aufgeklärt wird und so weiter das ist ja
ein zeitspiel man sich auf man sollte es
aufgeklärt seien 2024 fangen dann an
darüber nachzudenken
man muss auch ehrlich gesagt nicht viel
aufklären das sind menschen mit
zurückgebundenen arm und mit einem
schuss eine schusswunde im hinterkopf zu
hunderten was soll man denn da aufklären
wenn ja ob denn die russische propaganda
das dass die ukrainer selber waren wenn
hunderte von angehörigen erzählen wie
ihre ihre liebsten hingerichtet worden
sind glaubt irgendjemand dass sie sich
das ausgedacht haben dass die russen
waren damit dass propaganda haben und
hoffen dann nehmen sie die aktion gut
also da muss man nicht mehr viel
aufklären ich glaube all den ring die es
dort zehn und beschreiben ich glaube
paul ronzheimer ich glaube unseren
leuten vor ort die beschrieben haben zum
glück richtigerweise deutlich
beschrieben haben worum es dort geht und
was dort passiert ist und das liegt
jetzt das fundament
für konsequenzen und einmal noch ganz
wichtig jeder einzelne von uns ist da
betroffen ich finde das mittlerweile
decken tand zusagen wahrheit ist aber
kalt im april wenn in tausend kilometer
entfernt leute sterben ich finde es sehr
gut und speiseöl und mehl zu halten wenn
denn mario pohl leute verhungern ich
finde es eine art von
wohlstandsverwahrlosung die sogar den
umstand dass wir jahrelang über
toiletten fest rittergeschlecht
diskutiert haben wohl schon klar war
dass ein despot ein land nach dem
anderen über feld es legt offen in was
für einer scheinwelt verwöhnten
scheinwelt wir uns beim weinchen
versichert haben wie toll alles ist
jetzt ist klar was wirklich ist und
jetzt gilt es positiv formuliert
zusammenzustehen als westen und schnell
zu handeln nicht übermorgen eugen
nächstes jahr jetzt und zwar mit ganz
klaren wirtschaftlichen sanktionen wir
müssen uns erschwert nach schaffen mit
dem wir kämpfen ganz klare worte von
claus strunz dank rang